d'accord la tête d'un tout le monde
allait très bien mais 98 98 c'était
unique mec tout ce qu on appelle la
toque toute la nuit avec les darons
super ça grave d'où bah moi je
craindrais rien puisque j'avais deux ans
voilà je n'ai en 96 ça va les mecs ça y
est allé non par contre à capter une
bonne lepi disons 86 morts ça veut dire
que tu as jamais connu les prends ça
veut dire que tu es vieux que moi je
suis un peu une somme c'est juste que
les années 90 avait un autre charme et
oui tu peux pas comprendre les empêche
que j'ai grandi dans les années 2000
pour moi tout était plus facile
ici du nouveau millénaire il avait
tellement de choses à faire
c'est y aller ouais et passer leur
famille en somme pas sur nos téléphones
a connu l'arrivée dbz
yves et thomas ian et dm était les rois
du ebook mais pour faire marrer les
bottes suffisait caché dans son job
tout ça va aller mal et et je le trouve
sur wikipédia tu passes et lamar
chercher le sens du mot l'historien
virulente et les esprits car son père
était au ps
[Musique]
la chine
les souches après 90 versus 2006 on nous
avait dit un jour confirmait youtuber 90
versus 2000 on a laissé derrière nous
tous vous embrasser 9 heures déjeuner
on est tous à nous parents
on met des jeunes et pas très bon soyez
en super héros nous on a lui qui jouait
en 3d
la connu l'âge d'or 2 et a finalement
saisi les disputes avait un son de
bâtard vous y connaissez rien avec vos
mp3 doublé t il battu en revanche avec
des kilos c'est bien que sa musique soit
effectué passé sur un autre à la levée
de l'état
le climat canal plus et mieux avant
l'espérance
c'était
lundi versus 2006 on nous avait dit un
jour tu remets youtuber 90 versus nos
villes on a laissé derrière nous tout me
semble assez d'ampleur n'était jamais
innocente on est tous à nos parents on
était jeunes et pas très bon soyez en
super héros on est étudiant n'est pas
d'epo mais on a tout ce qu'il vous faut
l'ami du petit déjeuner l'ami ricoré
emad abbar malabat les ports du laitier
sont vos amis dans la vie
ok
on n'a pas donné
non
20/10 perçu ce domine si on nous avait
dit un jour qu'on regardera youtuber 90
versus 2000 on a laissé derrière nous
tout ce temps passé 9 heures déjeuner il
me semble dans des toiles aux parents
mon dd je n'ai pas très beau conte soyez
un super héros
mais on a aussi des bras le corps
chirac drucker les simpsons et south pas
au final on était les gamins
tête brûlée pokémon les billets ça qui
se bat on a aussi des points communs
sheeran drucker les simpsons et south
pas au final on était les mêmes gamin
et pokémon les billets l'esa qui soit
le corps jambes c'est un jeu commun sur
des lisiers vous je peux pas tous les
jeux gascons interne et ça moi j'ai deux
ans un truc pages écrit par tonne
acheminée en 2010
carole